"The Batman's" played a joke on all of us.
"I'm just here to unmask the truth about this
cesspool we call a city."
"The Batman" offers significant changes to
characters general audiences thought they
knew well.
All you have to do is take a look at the Caped
Crusader himself, played this time around
by Robert Pattinson.
While he's the World's Greatest Detective
in the comics, that side of him had never
really been explored in a live-action film
before.
That all changes in "The Batman" as he's on
the hunt for a mysterious serial killer going
by the name of Riddler.
He has to solve the clues, and to further
add to the detective aesthetic, Batman speaks
in voiceover like an old-school noir film.
Of course, some things are destined to remain
the same forever, such as Batman's eternal
struggle with the Joker.
In virtually every iteration of the character,
the Caped Crusader has to tussle with the
Clown Prince of Crime, and lo and behold,
the Joker does make a brief appearance in
"The Batman."
After the Riddler's safely in custody, he
speaks with his next-door cellmate, and while
he never mentions a name, it's fairly obvious
this character, played by Barry Keoghan, is
supposed to be the newest version of the Joker.
"Getting to be that, it's like – words can't
describe it."
For years, all of DC's cinematic efforts came
to exist under the banner of the DC Extended
Universe.
Similar to the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
this meant that all of the characters existed
under one roof, so Batman could appear in
a Superman movie and vice versa.
However, unlike the MCU, this venture has
become stilted in recent years as the massive
team-up film "Justice League" failed to ignite
a franchise.
Since that time, some movies have kept the
series going, like "Birds of Prey."
However, other DC projects have come to exist
in their own continuity, such as 2019's "Joker."
Prior to its release, there was confirmation
that "The Batman" would exist in its own separate
continuity.
However, there were questions if it would
connect with any other DC efforts, particularly
"Joker" where Joaquin Phoenix portrayed the
famed villain.
With the above-mentioned scene in "The Batman,"
we now know once and for all that "The Batman"
won't connect to anything that's come before.
By all appearances, a new Joker is in town.
However, that doesn't mean "The Batman" will
exist in a vacuum.
It's already been confirmed that two spinoffs
are in the works on HBO Max.
The first will center on the Gotham Police
Department while the other focuses on Colin
Farrell's Penguin.
There's even a possibility that if "The Batman
2" filmmakers don't want to use Joker as the
villain in that movie, he could pop up in
one of these shows to wreak havoc.
It would seem "The Batman" is forging a new
path ahead for DC projects, and while he may
be the Dark Knight, the future couldn't be
brighter.
"Don't throw your life away."
"Don't worry, honey – I've got nine of 'em."
With DC tampering with the multiverse in the
upcoming "Flash" movie, it's clear that while
some films will exist within the DCEU, others
will exist separately in their own universes.
Of course, as Marvel has already shown us
with "Spider-Man: No Way Home," the multiverse
is a delicate concept, and it can easily break
to the point where other realities merge with
others.
As of right now, three live-action Jokers
have appeared in DC theatrical films as of
late.
In addition to Barry Keoghan's cameo in "The
Batman," there's also Joaquin Phoenix's Oscar-winning
portrayal as the Clown Prince of Crime in
"Joker."
Jared Leto also recently revived his version
of the character for "Zack Snyder's Justice
League" after playing him for 2016's "Suicide
Squad."
That makes for three live-action Jokers out
there, not even getting into all of the cartoons
and video games that have featured him in
recent memory.
It's an intriguing development, especially
seeing how DC Comics has introduced the concept
of three Jokers in the mainline DC continuity.
In the limited series, "Batman: Three Jokers,"
Batman realizes that different versions of
Joker are out there.
Not only does it make for a thrilling adventure,
but it also serves as a meta-commentary on
the purpose and function of the villain in
these stories.
Could a live-action version of this story
materialize with the three Jokers we have
now uniting for one wild and crazy escapade?
It's a long shot, but wilder things have happened
in the world of comic book movies.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.